tout le monde s'est excusé aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur octobre alors
pourquoi je suis des vidéos seulement
maintenant sur ce jeu alors qu'il est
sorti il ya vraiment pas mal de temps et
qui a vraiment énormément youtuber qu'on
fait des vidéos dessus c'est parce qu'à
la gamescom j'ai eu la chance de jouer
sur la ps4 au deuxième octobre est donc
d'aller à sketches quelque chose comme
ça et je me suis dit [ __ ] c'est
excellent faut que je joue au premier
alors c'est parti
play on ne perdra plus de temps pour
incarner un poulpe voilà dessins de cp
et toi et we can qui s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui est un super jour lève-toi
l'effroi à l'aude apporte quoi alors
vous pressez que ce jeu est à la base un
projet d'étudiants de juste et plus qu'à
l'université
donc ce qui est excellent alors j'ai un
petit peu des commandos ne se retrouve
pas ce que c'est quand même bien what
the fuck on va dire que j'ai compris on
va tester commande alors walcott octobre
en suisse et instructions pour compléter
le tutoriel de skippy cap journal un
excès de hockey alors attendez ok
d'accord ça mange et couvrir commandes
luca moyen ogooué est champion champion
de gymnastique et de 2000 2011
alors move tout doit soit en off à l'art
alors il est où le doigt ce [ __ ] de
caméras de jeu castrais veulent pas de
ma carte mère faut juste que je n'étais
what ah bon excusez moi j'aimerais juste
jeté sur la veille par la fenêtre il ya
une fenêtre
voilà à quoi je vous fait penser
pardon ah excusez moi partons sausage
d'affaires d'alcoa ce qu'on trouve
toujours le bordel de merde [ __ ]
ouais et au gré bien journal twente
tutorial oryx port hobbit alors dit au
journal as ou sas a joué mouvement a dit
un autre jour commence où je dois où
j'ai pas encore été découverts il se
prend vraiment pour quelqu un appui
anniversary alors est ce qu'on doit
faire
alors banana from kitchen suite promet
living room octopus dole von teese rumba
new build the mac olalalala faut aller
partout il faut aller partout dans
toutes les chambres alors là dans la
kitchen tagada tu t'attends à merde
allez à là bas amateurs à double pad e
double au faut laver la salle de bal
ferai comme ça pardon non pardon allons
lave on lave on lave comme on l'a alors
quoi d'autre ça peut-être pardon je veux
juste l'avait mad as we will i am et les
ouates big disk mais mais mais excusez
moi je la vends ma tasse pour demain
matin un comme ça je la case suppliante
ce look du tos hier à l'avancé vers
l'avant je veux laver les pieds dans la
vaisselle c'est mon pays la vaisselle a
été fait on des palais
oprah passer le balai non ne mange pas
ne mange pas le ballet octobre date s'il
te plaît dans arrête de prendre pour
booth qui aa il passe le balai est le
manche
moi j'aime passer le balai avec le
manche allez allez allez y est presque
là allez ma petite pieuvre vaduz petite
pieuvre on a move dataflow taxant d'
excellent pour une fois que je suis
content de passer le balai et de faire
la vaisselle
ok alors info juste trop juste ranger la
table on n'a pas d'idées où on n'a pas
dérangé le sol
donc je m'emballe ecc je mets tout par
ce terrain non excusez moi pardon aux
excuses et moi madame h
pardon oui la mort d'une étoile à table
elle est trop contente tu regarde par
terre tu fait clean and the fridge un
dégage le bras aulas d'accord donc c'est
tout à fait normal quand tu ouvres ton
frigo chez toi ça fait ce bruit la
décroissance rigaux qu'est ce qui fait
j'espère qu'a fait ils vont pas nous
dire un truc style nettoie le sol
ah mais je sais que ce n'est pas les cno
qui met prend les allemands se joue sur
les nerfs ce jeu [ __ ] aller le dernier
a ouvre toi
ah non à elle le frigo tu continues je
te perds ses cheveux dans la gueule ok
j'en ai marre et regarde elodie les plus
à l'est moi je suis à grave
sa prof bounouar cnao groupe the banana
elle ou la banane à la banane ou non la
banane où est elle ah ah ah non elle est
revenue dans sa main donne moi la bonne
[Musique]
laissez moi sortir cette [ __ ] accusé est
parfois là on a la banane
il ne manque plus que trois trucs et on
peut habiller le mannequin si ça c'est
pas incroyable nous sommes nous entrés
dans la seconde pièce
donc moi juste le truc alors qu'ici on
doit faire notre dame the tower of
blocks ok faire tomber ça tient bon et
le web je suis noir écaille beckett oui
c'est une info que j'y met un but pardon
excuse moi je vais te le mettre ton but
tu veux pas laisser entrer le ballon se
te plait je te donnerai un carambar à
celui-là il est pour toi qui as hier
cette vidéo alors tu te la fermes match
no 1
tiens tiens un pauvre mon pouf pouf pouf
pouf maintien c'est mon notre ferme
course
[Musique]
ok ou ont fait la course du siècle
deuce to miss kate wolof du club elle
est où la clé tommy espèce de petit
bâtard donne moi la clé est ce que tu
aimes mes vielles ils sont bons je suis
à poules oies
je marche sur la tête quand je t'aime
pas oulala cette pieuvre boy est un peu
chaque chose est une mission quentin
mais ouvre toi ou je casse la vitre avec
la clé
au faux sont est ce cette veste à
oui je suis l'homme le plus heureux du
monde
oh et si on se faisait un petit calamars
grillés une télé une télécommande
ban des tentacules mois normal achetez
mon poisson fuji manteau de très bons
poissons et sushi d'accord as we know
you your octopus and i'm coming to get
your qu'elle est très très peur à a
atteint suivant attention à la toque de
30 mètres bois bien voilà on a fait des
trucs il nous en reste deux à faire ce
sera dans le second épisode est sûrement
le dernier épisode que tout le monde
puisse à bientôt au revoir
[Musique]